i've drawn a crazy looking function here
in yellow and what i want to think about
is when this function takes on maximum
values and minimum values and for the
sake of this video we can assume that
the graph of this function just keeps
getting lower and lower and lower as x
becomes more and more negative and lower
and lower and lower as x goes beyond the
interval that i've depicted right over
here so what is the maximum value that
this function takes on
well we can eyeball that it looks like
it's at this point it looks like it's at
that point right over there so we would
call this a global
a global maximum
a global maximum the function never
takes on a value larger than this so we
could say that we have a global maximum
at the point at the point x naught
because f of
f of x naught
is greater than or equal to f of x for
any other x in the domain and that's
pretty obvious when you look at it like
this
now do we have a global minimum point
the way that i've drawn it well no this
function can take on arbitrarily
arbitrarily negative values it can it
approaches negative infinity as x
approaches negative infinity it
approaches positive infinity so we have
let me write this down we have
no
global
we have no global
minimum
now let me ask you a question do we have
local minima or local maximum when i say
minima it's just the plural of minimum
and maxima is just the plural of maximum
so do we have a local minima here or
local minimum here well
a local minimum you could imagine means
that that value of the function at that
point is lower than the points around it
so right over here it looks like we have
a local minimum
local
we have a local minimum and i'm not
giving you a very rigorous definition
here but one way to think about it is we
can say that we have a local minimum
point at x1 is if we have a region
around x1 where f of x1 is less than an
f of x for any x in this region right
over here and it's pretty easy to
eyeball too this is a low point for any
of the values of f around it right over
there
now do we have any other local minima
well it doesn't look like we do now what
about local maxima
well this one right over here let me do
it in let me do it in purple i don't
want to get people confused actually let
me do it in this color this point right
over here looks like a local maximum
local not locks that would have to deal
with salmon local
local
maximum right over there
local maximum so we could say at the
point
x1 at the point oh sorry at the point x2
we or we have a local maximum point at
x2 because f of x2 is larger than f of x
for any x around a neighborhood around
x2 i'm not being very rigorous but you
can see it just by looking at it so
that's fair enough we've identified all
of the maxima and minima often called
the extrema for this function
now how can we identify those if we knew
something about the derivative of the
function well let's look at the
derivative at each of these at each of
these points
so at this first point right over here
if i were to try to visualize the
tangent line let me do that in a better
color than brown
if i were to try to visualize the
tangent line it would look something
like that so the slope here is zero so
we would say that f prime
of x naught is equal to zero the slope
of the tangent line at this point is
zero what about over here well once
again the tangent line the tangent line
would look something like that so once
again we would say
f prime at x one at x one is equal to
zero
what about over here
well here the tangent line is actually
not well defined we have a positive
slope going into it and it immediately
jumps to being a negative slope so over
here f prime of x2 is not defined
not let me just write undefined
undefined
so we have an interesting and once again
i'm not rigorously proving it to you i
just want you to get the intuition here
we see that if we have some type of a
extrema and we're not talking about when
we're when x is at an endpoint of an
interval just to be clear what i'm
talking about when i'm talking about x
as an endpoint of an interval we're
saying let's say that the function is
let's say we have an interval from
there
so let's say a function starts right
over there and then keeps going this
would be a maximum point but it would be
an endpoint we're not talking about
endpoints right now we're talking about
when we have points in between or when
we when when our interval is infinite so
we're not talking about we're not
talking about points like that or points
like this we're talking about the points
in between
the points in between
so if you have a point inside of an
interval
it's going to be a minimum or maximum
and we see the intuition here if you
have so non-endpoint
non endpoint
non endpoint min
or
max
min or max
at let's say x is equal to a so if you
know that you have a minimum or maximum
point at some point x is equal to a and
x isn't the end point x isn't the end
point of some interval this tells you
something interesting at least we have
the intuition we see that the derivative
at x is equal to a is going to be equal
to zero or the derivative at x is equal
to a is going to be
un
is going to be undefined and we see that
in each of these cases derivative is 0
derivative is 0. derivative is undefined
and we have a word for these for these
points where the derivative is either 0
or the derivative is undefined
we call them critical points
we call them
critical
critical points
so for the sake of this function the
critical point
the critical
point the critical points
are if we we could include x sub 0
we could include x sub 1
at x sub 0 and x sub 1 the derivative is
0 and x sub 2 where the function is
undefined
now so if we have a non-endpoint minimum
or maximum point then it's going to be a
it's going to be a critical point but
can we say it the other way around if we
find a critical point
where the derivative is 0 or the
derivative is undefined is that going to
be a maximum or minimum point and to
think about that let's imagine
let's imagine
this point right over here so let's call
this x sub three
if we look at the tangent line right
over here if we look at the slope right
over here it looks like f prime of x sub
3 is equal to 0. so based on our
definition of critical point x sub 3
would also be a critical point but it
does not appear to be a minimum or a
maximum point so minimum or maximum
point that's not at an that's not an end
point it's definitely going to be a
critical point but a critical point but
being a critical point by itself does
not mean you're at a minimum or maximum
point so just to be clear at all of
these points we're at a minimum or
maximum point
this we're at a critical point all of
these are critical points but this is
not a minimum or maximum point in the
next video we'll start to think about
how can you can how you can
differentiate or how you can tell
whether you have a minimum or maximum at
a critical point